so uh we can pull up the map real quick
for those that uh don't understand
there's a story I think it was in 2012
the guardian reported that as of 2009 us
intelligence wanted to destabilize Syria
because we wanted to build an a a
natural gas pipeline from I believe it
was the Persian Gulf through Iraq was it
the Persian Gulf it was it was through
Iraq through Syria through turkey into
Europe uh spec partly or I should say uh
majority of the the largest reason why
was to offset the Russian gas prom
natural gas Monopoly
Syria said no Syria is allied with
Russia and outright refused to allow
this of course they also have Russia as
a military base in Tartus which is uh
where is there it is right right here Y
and so uh uh conveniently for the United
States whatever you believe Syria falls
into civil war with the United States on
the side opposing Assad whatever side
that may be and uh uh it it seems like
now with Ukraine with barisma all of
these things are deeply connected to we
are trying to get cheap energy into
Europe it's a very simple way of putting
it nordstream gets blown
up yeah where's the US military in
Syria it's in the Northeast where all
where the Koko oil fields are well Trump
trump told us
thatz when Trump tried to pull them out
yeah they lied about it if I understand
correctly they're actually uh they were
in Iraq based in Iraq and and going to
Syria from Iraq but if I andum wanteded
to get our troops out of Syria it's
really funny because when was the for
formal Declaration of deployment right
it's like just all of a sudden it's like
we have troops in Sy it's like wait when
well the thing is but the re the reason
that there the reason there was no
declaration is because it was special
forces so it was like Delta and stuff
like so those dudes they and then they
lied to the American
people the American people voted for a
president who was saying no more to
these Garbage Wars you know what grinds
my gears that that was that was me in
2008 Barack Obama and and I was and and
and you know I very much was listening
to what Ron Paul was talking my friends
were all very into Ron Paul and then
when it came down to the actual election
my friends were just like dude he's
clearly not like the establishment this
is our one chance and I was like okay
whatever I mean I'm in Chicago I'll vote
for him ites I don't know if it means
anything and then he went what was one
of the first things he did was he bombed
a village of women and children I think
killed 23 or something like that in
Yemen in Hoda right was perhaps all I
know is I'm at these anti-war protests
they're saying George W bush is Hitler
and then Obama's like OB Obama yeah I
thought we were talking about the Trump
era sorry oh no no Obama did yeah yeah
so George W bush they're calling him
Hitler they're waving these signs and
then with the Hitler mustache so I'm
like okay well I'll vote for Obama and
then I think it was like within a few
weeks actually I think it was like three
days later after his inauguration women
and children killed 23 or so and then I
was just like oh okay no that was well
there's a lesson learned that was my
ticket out of the democratic party
forever was oh that was me right I was
just like oh so everybody just lied to
me and I'm an idiot I was pissed and
then I didn't vote again for 12 years
well I mean it was so much crazier than
like just believing in it it was like he
got a Nobel Prize before he came in a
Nobel Peace Prize I almost I I I was
really really really upset when that
happened because I was like he literally
did nothing this means this is
cheapening the value of every single
Nobel that has been given up before
right he got an award for being not
George Bush and there was no reason to
believe other than you know he had a
nice smile and was charismatic there was
no reason to believe that he was going
to have any different policy there was
no and there was no change in fact he
shot just as many missiles and violated
the Constitution just as badly and worse
he killed he killed I think he killed
more American citizens than any other
president I mean I think he's the well
he's the only guy that ever targeted
American citizens he the only without
yeah and and targeted him without
without judicial you know without due
process what what it I'm just so
disgusted by all this man sick the the
the the idea that we've talk I can't
remember who I was arguing with but they
were saying that the president has a
wide uh what's what's the uh uh birth
not birth but like a mandate in terms of
defending this country and if that means
American citizens overseas I'm like no
it doesn't that is so that is such
fabrication to to apologize for the guy
they like doing illegal that's all
it is dude I'm sick of this too and I've
been thinking okay Federal Reserve
formed in 1913 World War I begins in
1914 maybe a coincidence maybe World War
II ends in 1945 Israel is formed in
1947 maybe probably okay I'm done with
the coincidences now the British and the
French wanted that area of the world
it's we've been In Perpetual War for 115
years this is one war it started in 1914
we're still there we're still in it no
no it's not one it's been cold for a
while it's been proxy it's the same
thing man you can reduce it all
the way back thousands of years it began
in 1914 with this banking take over it
didn't I you know you know what really
frustrates me as i' Occupy Wall Street
and they were having a general assembly
meeting to determine what should be the
goal and one guy stands up waving his
arms like you just said fracking is
everything why can't you see it I'm not
saying the conflict began in 1914 I'm
saying this war the Great War began in
1914 and it has not ended the reason
World War why the alliances form why why
did the because they wanted to control
the world with economy man no no no why
did the alliances form that led to World
War I uh cousins birth rights money the
conflict well before this you can get as
reductive as you want it goes back
forever but the banking cartels the bank
for international settlements the
Federal Reserve was formed in 1913 and
it set the world Napoleonic Wars and and
and uh what was it Rothschild yeah the
The Legend of coming back and say Yes
Napoleonic wars were European Wars yeah
and what do you think World War I was a
global war with what what countries un
it was mostly based in in it was mostly
based in Europe and World War II
it's when you took when North America
got involved there when we started
calling them world wars and with World
War II you had the Japanese empire which
was relatively separate from what the
the the what was happening in Europe but
yes even the Napoleonic War as you could
argue was like World War these countries
had colonies everywhere Australia New
Zealand there's there's french
uninhabited islands near Antarctica like
so it was World War it's been there's
been colonization since like the 1600s
when when theen when the French Empire
was at war with all the other countries
of Europe that included all of their
colonies around the world as well they
fought were there too there was they
fought against the Russians the Dutch
Ian what you I think what you're you're
describing is the fact that the when the
Federal Reserve came into being it
allowed the government to print money
which allowed the government to finance
War right and also profit off of it I
don't know that that's the case because
I think that they could profit off of
War long before the Federal Reserve but
you get to blow things up and then loan
them give them as much of your money as
you want your Fe I mean anyway start
interrupt maybe but the but the the
point is that the the existence of the
Federal Reserve
unleashes and and basically not just the
Federal Reserve but but money that's not
actually T pegged to uh to Gold they can
manipulate it much easier if they're
printing money that's not pegged to Gold
but the existence of the Federal Reserve
is what really gave governments the
specifically the United States
government the ability to fund Wars and
when you have the ability to fund Wars
then they'll go ahead and they'll look
for reasons to go to but it's not like
all the wars that you're describing are
not the same thing I think it's all one
war they say World War I and World War
II it's semantic in
my then then then then you need to go
back further than that you need to go
back to where these alliances come from
I'm talking about this war is began in
1914 this war this is a World War it's
been going on for 110 years and it's
Banker control you okay you are ignoring
the history of Europe there's other Wars
that have happened I'm not saying that
this is the first war I'm saying it's
the first we're still in this war it
hasn't stopped yet and it's been cold it
was cold and now it's a c war with China
and it's like been proxy Ian when you
say China's involved in the same War you
need to go back World War you are
choosing to hyperfocus on because that's
what you care about this this banking
War started in 1914 no it didn't no I
think when do you think that the Federal
Reserve War Began before the Federal
Reserve existed like what are you
talking about you are you are the
Federal Reserve is a symptom a creation
because of these things I mean the
history started that freaking thing to
control people and you're ignoring where
where they come came from and where
their wealth comes from and what
conflicts they were involved in you are
choosing to H on the Federal Reserve
because that's your thing but bro it's
all of this is reductive no no it's not
man it's a war and it's semantic to call
the Cold War not World War World War I
is the Cold War it's the same so
Ian the but the the the the world wars
of the 20th century were Wars of
ideology it was really people figuring
out because in the in the 18th or in the
19th century um you had the basically
the the Industrial Revolution made it
possible for people to not live just
agrarian in an agrarian society you had
people going to cities and stuff you had
this massive explosion in people that
could be become philosophers and blah
blah blah and so in the 18 in the 19th
century there was a lot of philosophers
they were they came up with the ideas of
socialism fascism was was was the idea
was was created liberalism was was a
creation that was also in the 18th
century and the wars of the 20th or 19th
century I'm sorry Wars of the 20th
century were kind of or at least the
first half we kind of trying to hash out
what what system works best you had
socialism you had fascism you had
liberalism and it the way that it worked
out at the end of the 20th century is it
looked like liberalism probably was the
best system for for Humanity because it
allows people to make mistakes without
having it being a top- down control so
what you're describing is really more of
humans trying to figure out the best way
to to organize their societies and and
fighting over the way to organize
because you went from Total War
feudalism in the in the 19th century and
then you went into capitalist societies
and then that that's where you had
enough production where people could
start to you know just talk about
Socialism or Fascism and whether the
state should be in control or whether
the individual should be in control but
these things are all symptoms or the the
wars that you're talking about are all
symptoms of trying of of humans trying
to figure out the best way to organize
their society we're currently in fascism
right now and it's not working very well
we're not in fascism right now we are
private corporate let me let me finish
this because I want to go on but there's
a war between England and France called
A Hundred Years War Wars can go on that
long so just consider that maybe we've
been in like it's not normal to be at
War like we're not in how long was true
war is the war is the norm for all of
human history I don't think so it
absolutely is I mean you weren't there
how do you know I I don't I don't think
we have to be
we've been in a war my whole life but
we've just been winning it the whole
time we've been we've been in a Siege
where America has 150 military bases
controlling people's behavior war and
violence are the norm for Human
Society peace is extremely rare and we
are living in an anomalous time where
generally our society is at peace now
the world's not I I know I know that
it's not the world that's why I'm saying
our society Western Society is at peace
and it is anomalous it is not normal in
human history to not be at War there has
been if you look at human history it is
drenched in Blood and made of piles of
bodies the fact that we can get up in
the morning and not worry about
dying like I'm not in that place anymore
a huge huge it's it's totally unique to
our time and place I don't feel that I
I'm worried about dying that's fine
pretend like we're not is just a ticking
Time Bomb I I understand what you're
saying but I'm trying to what I'm trying
to do is give you a little perspective
and or to to pull you back from the
brink because we are actually in one of
the most peaceful times in human history
we and and human history is full of War
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time